i wanted to ask you i had t-rel up here
and i saw you went up to no jumper and
did an interview with him
can you for people who aren't aware as
to why that was a big deal man because
there might be people who are watching
this who aren't from l.a who aren't hip
to the politics of la so why was that
such a big deal that you and t rail sat
with each other yeah man number one
shout out to t real man great guy yeah
real 100 dude solid dude you feel me
you know i feel like you know we come
from the same [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying you know south central l.a you
know what i'm saying the hoods the you
know what i'm saying
going to jail
you know so it's like
at some point you know what i'm saying
you gotta you gotta you gotta show the
young [ __ ] that you know i'm saying we
can elevate we can grow
you know what i'm saying something
beyond just you know what i'm saying
doing that we can't get do business
together [ __ ] can't get money together
you know what i'm saying so yeah because
your guys neighborhoods obviously don't
get along it's probably the
most notorious disagreement in l.a
in the la street politics
so like i just thought that that was
dope man because i do feel like
eventually somebody's gotta
you know
show everybody that yeah somebody gotta
do it you feel me just cuz based on the
politics you know what i'm saying you
know how la is like oh you ain't
supposed to do this you ain't supposed
to holler right there ain't supposed to
talk to your name supposed to kick it
with them
you feel me but you your own man at the
end of the day like you feel me and my
homies
they [ __ ] with that damn they ain't
against it they wasn't opposed to it you
know what i'm saying [ __ ] can't be
like oh [ __ ] you wouldn't did that with
me it don't work like that